uh good morning and welcome to the work
work session on House Bill
378 um regarding the information
provided to survivors of sexual assault
regarding their um existing rights when
we last met we had had an amendment that
I did include for anybody everybody here
that was Amendment 2357 H um the way
that we had moved in the subcommittee
was to move um to have an information
information specifically provided to
survivors of sexual assault so that
right after they had been stripped of
that power and autonomy and their rights
during their
victimization they started that
transition to a Survivor by knowing
their rights as a survivor of sexual
assault we had spelled out a lot of the
information that was included in the 115
page guidance document from the
Department of Justice and the attorney
general which outlines those rights the
times for collection um and everything
else that a victim that a Survivor
because once you are heard you become a
you you move towards being a Survivor
instead of a victim for that Survivor to
understand what rights they have so that
they can make sure that their rights are
fully protected and begin that healing
process as we did that we got some
feedback from the Coalition um that
spoke about how if we put those details
into law when there's the next revision
of the guidelines then we'd have to come
back and do that in law um we have an
amendment that would put this
requirement into Ru making and make it
and it would charge the Department of
Justice with adopting rules to create a
document or documents summarized and I'm
reading off of this amendment it's going
to be hot off the presses as soon as it
is released from OS it will be printed
and come down to us but it is in this
format um it would say it says that the
department yes Madam chair perhaps our
researcher could step down the hall and
make copies there are copies and they've
already been distributed for our guests
yes oh okay yes they're already sitting
there you said that it hot off the
presses will be this amendment right now
it's just in the text form it literally
is in the final review this one we're
not consider in that was the one that we
considered at the last work session and
I'm speaking to our Evolution from that
amendment to where we are now and uh
that this amendment in official form
will be coming this the piece of paper
we should be working on I'm looking at
both of them showing you where we
started and where we are now I'm trying
to give you a a walk with a crosswalk
here thank you so on this new one the
official one will be coming down
momentarily um in section one um Roman
the new Roman 2 says that the Department
of Justice shall adopt rules pursuant to
create a document or document
summarizing the information required by
the sexual assault survivors rights so
that victims of sexual assault
Healthcare Providers and the general
public can easily access the key points
of the protocols required in paragraph
one which is that 115 page document
necessary to protect the rights of
sexual assault Survivors by placing this
into rulemaking Authority it will have
an opportunity for review for all
stakeholders and for everybody who is a
Survivor as well to make sure that that
information that they needed in that
moment of need is available um to the to
anybody else when they go through that
experience and it also means that it
will be easily adaptable when there are
new rules under 21 M8 D1 um which is a
standardized protocol kit and domestic
violence protocol that this form can be
changed and updated this document can be
changed and updated at the same
time if you look to where we and and so
then this form is referenced um in the
sexual assault survivors rights where
you're they're already have the right to
be informed of writing a polici
governing the collection and
preservation of sexual assault evidence
kits it just adds including the
information required by um
194 it we also um had the definition
about a sexual assault Survivor I really
hadn't understood some of the push back
on it until I recognized that what
myself and others call attempted rape we
call that because in the process of
trying to rape somebody they were groped
which is a misdemeanor sexual assault
that that terminology may not be
acknowledged by all so in breaking down
the um what a sexual assault Survivor is
instead of putting those categories
ahead of the rsas it says that a sexual
assault Survivor means any individual
who asserts that they have been subject
to an offense under the statute es for
aggravated fonus fonus and misdemeanor
sexual assault including but not limited
to the penetrative or non-penetrative
sexual assault because if there's not
penetration but there's sexual contact
that is the misdemeanor or
administrating of a drug or other
intoxicating substance as a part of a
sexual assault which falls under the
reference statutes that is already in
law that if somebody has drugged you in
order to have sexual contact or more
with you that is that is against the law
that is already included in the
standardized protocol um and then it
also for those those people who don't
know where to go and don't know what to
do and all they know how to say is that
that somebody tried to rape me that it
says that an individual reporting an
attempted rape who asserts sexual
contact as defined and described shall
not be denied survivors rights because
of a lack of knowledge of the correct
legal terminology so that is just to
make sure that everybody is aware of
their rights and they can begin that
healing
process in uh section four of here it's
at the bottom of this new page um it
adds the Attorney General would need to
post prominently that document and it
outlines what it needs to have that is
the rights under the section and under
the um Regular victim's rights and the
policy is cons governing the collection
and preservation of a sexual assault
evidence collection kit as established
including how long after the assault the
different types of samples may be
collected or generally collected and the
fact that bringing your clothes and the
other things you had with you are
valuable because they may have evidence
and if a vict if a Survivor doesn't know
that that's one of the reasons why so
few of these assaults are actually
successfully prosecuted in New
Hampshire and then um and then also
including that information about how if
you say that it's attempted rape what
makes it a misdemeanor sexual assault so
that you actually understand if that
line that legal line has been crossed or
not um and and then finally it requires
a healthc care provider law enforcement
officer or other employee of an entity
listed in paragraph one who in the
course of their professional Rel
responsibilities has contact with a
sexual assault Survivor shall provide
the individual with a document intended
for sexual assault survivors provided by
the Attorney General pursuant to
paragraph three or an internally created
document which contains at minimum the
same material information the reason for
allowing them to do that is that a lot
of times when you go to the hospital you
end up getting a out that looks like
everybody else's but it's specific to
those whatever condition you're in for
you can just have that boring stack of
papers that looks like you might be in
for an for appendectomy but it'll have
your rights included there in the same
boring format so that the person sitting
next to you won't know why you're
there so um with that I I would like to
know if there's if um any of the
committee members have any
questions subcommittee members
representative
Weber I just wanted to thank you for all
the work you've put in on this um and I
I would very much like to hear from
members of the Coalition who are here
today because one of the reasons that we
had yet another hearing yet work session
it's not a hearing uh was to get their
input so absolutely thank you do that I
would appreciate it I am definitely
planning on calling on them I just
wanted to know if there was anything
initially from a member of the committee
um and with that if there's anybody here
um that wanted to speak to this amend
this bill as
amended good morning Madam chair members
of the committee um my name is Pamela KY
and I am the public policy specialist at
the New Hampshire Coalition against
domestic in sexual violence and and I'm
here today um with our uh co-director of
the sexual assault nurse examiner
program Janet Carol who can speak to
some of the technical aspects of this
bill I think unfortunately I would just
seeing this amendment now I would need
to be able to confer um with some of our
colleagues and partners in this work um
to get a better sense of what how that
would work um in the jail car process um
but I think we still have um some
questions and concerns and would just
really appreciate this to be further
studied but I'm happy to turn it over to
my colleague good morning
um as you guys are aware there's there's
several um protocols with the Attorney
General's office
that that go are for sexual assault okay
there's a model protocol which is a
multi-disciplinary protocol it's it's
over a 100 Pages um and that might have
been what was referenced at the last
meeting I don't know or this last
subcommittee meeting um in that section
it does um refer the medical folks
there's only a couple of pages in it
regarding medical uh it refers you to
115 page document which clearly defines
the process for collecting um drug
facilitated sexual assault specimens
should that occur um I think it's
important to know that um patients
present with many different histories um
if a patient came in and said I feel
like I was drugged but there's no way
anything occurred whether that be I um I
was walking with my friends and that's
when I started to feel funny I was in a
safe place there's no way anything
occurred it wouldn't
necess uh a sexual assault evidence
collection kit okay um if same type of
thing is well no I was able to hail a
Uber or a taxi and you know no physical
contact would have occurred it would not
necess necessitate I can't pronounce
that word um a sexual Sal evidence
collection kit okay um if a patient was
to say you know I feel like I was
drugged or I know I was drugged um but I
was able to get away I was able to you
know lock myself in a secured area or
get to my neighbor's home or something
like that I know nothing
occurred a sexual assault evidence
collection kit would not be completed in
those times but if a patient came and
said I think I was drugged and I don't
recall this time to this time and I
don't know who had access to my body or
if anything could have been done 100%
this kit would be opened and would be
provided to every single patient you
know if they wanted that option and that
is clearly written in the medical
protocol um that the Attorney General's
office has um and it's it's followed at
the
hospitals sorry representative
kman thank you madam chair and thank you
for being here um and thank you for
explaining those um examples of
scenarios where a collection kit would
be open and utilized and where it
wouldn't um so I it's but from what you
said it sounded like if someone was
sexually assaulted and possibly drugged
sexually assaulted I mean the
misdemeanor sexual assault if they were
grouped um that under the current
attorney general rules that you would
not um as long as they remembered that
they were not pen ated you would not
then that would not call for the kit to
be used so this could be opened if the
patient provided that
history yes but if the patient provides
a history of no nothing occurred no one
could have gotten to me you know I've
secured myself I was you know I hailed
an Uber it wouldn't necess this wouldn't
be warranted okay follow up yes follow
up um okay so it I know that you just
got to look at the um Amendment but it
seems like the amendment is in line with
that current practice where only if a
MISD demean or sexual assault was
experienced such as groping um
and um the victim presented themselves
at the hospital and reported such then
the kit would be open so it sounds like
there's no
um that they articulate well would you
agree I um I I think we would just
definitely need some more time to look
at this and look at the statute and make
sure that we're not accidentally also
excluding someone by listing specific
parts of RSA
632a um because I think the the term
sexual assault Survivor was
intentionally broad um but also to make
sure that it was encompassing all of the
crimes in partnership with the um RSA
21m so the victims Bill of Rights um so
I think this the spirit of this I think
is is something that we agree with and
we really appreciate the intent because
absolutely everyone should know their
rights and should be presented their
rights um but I think just the technical
component and making sure we're not
missing something here representative
Weber thank you so much and and thank
you for your comments you you do
understand we're under a significant
time pressure because we are on Deadline
uh does it make you um more or less
reassured that the
same um three statutes criminal statutes
RSA 632 A2 632 A3 and 632 A4 which were
in the amendment from last week which I
believe you did have a chance to review
are the same ones referred to here so
there has been as far as I'm aware and
and representative Lyon will correct me
if I'm wrong about this they are the
same statutes so they would cover uh the
the same criminal offenses that we were
talking about
before
and if so is it not true that what I'm
hearing is that they are closely aligned
with what the situations that we're
hearing that
uh the kits are offered
now yes in those situations that I
provided absolutely that is what's
provided now again it goes down to the
patient history and what they're able to
tell us that's what really guides
whether or not one of these is utilized
thank you thank you do you object to
somebody who comes in and says that
somebody tried to rape me um asking them
if somebody groped them if they touched
any of those intimate body parts
um in a way that um in a way that wasn't
consensual do you oppose you oppose the
idea of of asking um if they met those
conditions of a sexual assault when
somebody says that somebody tried to
rape
me that could be part of a history
taking absolutely do you think it should
be part of a history
taking yes it would be okay thank you um
and then um uh representative
Palmer I just have a a question that has
been sort of bothering me in the in the
that it seems like this the title of the
bill or the how it's listed um and it
says just end sentence from a patient
who may have been drugged or sexually
assaulted that we've somehow gotten a
little hung up on the ore where I think
the intent of this is not to not about
the people who are drugged it's about
people who are sexually assaulted and
maybe they were drugged too and I just
want to make sure that that we're not
that that's not one of the
um reasons that you're uncomfortable
because I don't the act the the title
here says that but the bill doesn't say
that yes thank you um and then um
finally I appreciate you coming here and
giving us the feedback on the previous
um Amendment um part of the reason we're
meeting now sort of at the 11th hour is
that the response from the Coalition was
about a week later than we had asked for
um we still took all the comments that
you had and Incorporated them into this
language we had some other bills that we
were working with which is why we tried
to get to the state sooner um but in
good faith we incorporated all the
feedback from the Coalition and perhap
and in drafting it actually went further
than we otherwise would have to to have
a good faith work and so we're hoping
that in good faith you will also work
with us as we move forward on this bill
with this amendment yeah no thank you so
much and I think um we just wanted to
make sure we reached out to all of the
various Partners law enforcement
prosecutors um members of um different
medical facilities and uh folks in this
work and just make sure that we got all
of the feedback we absolutely could so
we could be as well informed as possible
so thank you for your patience and for
incorporating our recommendations and
we'd be happy to keep working with you
on this um thank you and um and then I
guess the final final thing to point out
is that it does when it lists the
statutes it then says including but not
limited to so that it's not excluding
anybody who does have a right to that
all right thank you we'll take this back
to our partners thanks thank you
okay representative not up them I have
um a question um how long are the kits
retained um and and I I'm sure that's
under another statute but um um yes that
there is another statute I believe
there's a statute for that but I know
that within the guidelines they have a
whole part that's set out in that so if
you think that that information would be
something that's helpful to include for
the survivors that's something we can
make note of here um so that they can we
can make sure that when they make this
document through administrative rules we
can do that and it'll also since it's
just referencing and trying to get a
summary of the existing rights that'll
be the best place to make sure that we
understand exactly what is stated um
within that form and I think that that
means that we don't need to try and
figure that out now in this back and
forth process between the House and
Senate but go because it's pretty
administrative to do it through
administra rules okay thank you very
much thank
you
um I guess um I just wanted to find out
if the amendment has gone to house
committee services and or if we're still
waiting for
it I would love that that way we can uh
we can look at the actual one and just
make sure we didn't miss a word thank
you so much representative
Reed um and so as we wait for that I
know the reason this process is so
important is that it's the need to move
from being a victim to being a Survivor
and um I I think that this is one that
we really tried to look at all of the
language all the feedback that we had
and really make sure that we got just to
that me of the information to reference
within itself here what is was already
supposed to be
provided so representative Weber
thank you madam chair and I I just I I
want to present my thinking on this um
I'm very much in two minds uh uh I'm I'm
definitely going to vote for the
amendment because I think it um solves
many issues that were there in the
original bill
um what I am still waffling about
frankly is what I have heard from the
people who are the
practitioners is that what we have here
is already being
done and when what we have is already
being done my inclination is not to mess
with
it
um so I'm not at all sure once having
voted for the amendment whether I'm
going to vote for the underlying bill or
not um I I sincerely appreciate all the
work that's been
done to date and I may change my mind
again sometime between now and when we
have to vote on it as a full house so I
just want to make sure that everybody
knows that
I'm uh whatever happens today I'm not
particularly solid on it but I do think
that we've come along way in terms of
articulating and understanding what
happens
and again I think that everybody is very
very um concerned about
turning victims into survivors and
giving them back their power over their
bodies and their lives
so I just wanted to I think we're all as
one on that the problem is how we get
there thank you um the reason why this
bill came forward in the first place was
there was a Survivor who knew the laws
knew the statutes but still were not
provided with the kit in their time of
need um I I know that there's other
times when when we recognize that even
if it's just a few people who are having
a challenge um it's something that we
need to recognize um the biggest part
here is that this summary form would be
available to the doctors so that instead
of so that if they're not the ones who
are giving the the the test um they need
to know some amount of information but
when you put put 115 page for I'll ask
the doctors on the committee but if you
put a 115 page document of something
that you need to know enough to refer
but not enough to do the actual
procedure would it be beneficial to have
a summary document prepared by the same
people that that per that um that
created the larger document giving you
that information as a Frontline Doctor
Who first Encounters this patient to
know whether you should refer on or
whether it's not a case to refer is that
a helpful thing to the doctors on the
committee well since you're asking so
just looking back to when I did work in
the ER and this this was actually
something that came across the the ER
well both ER that that um had protocols
and so um I really and and to be honest
they had nurses who knew better than I
did so I it would be you
know certainly it would it would be
helpful to have something that you could
look at but most of the
time there was the you know sort of the
hospital protocol that was there the
same nurse would you know take over and
then I would be left to just doing any
medical things that came up that were
beyond the the um the whole assault kit
so I guess sort of the answer is I'm I'm
not sure how much difference it would
make to the actual practice of me doing
that having said that I was not an ER
trained physician it was just small
hospitals you you do what you have to do
so they probably have more training than
I did in that particular
area thank
you
okay I I I just oh I'm gonna keep going
just because we're waiting for the
document to come down um I I just think
that uh being able to have a summary
there's so much information in front of
all our providers in front of our First
Responders and in front of everybody
that being able to consolidate it to
something where you know a friend could
say you know you know Jane um yes I
support you this is something you should
go ahead and report this because this is
you know they this is illegal this does
qualify you for this test kit and I
recognize that there's a lot that is not
actually prosecuted um we killed a
couple trees giving you this the reality
of sexual assault in New Hampshire it
was a 2006 document in this it actually
speaks about some of those
misperceptions some of the hurdles to
reporting and by knowing what's going to
happen if you go in and knowing if you
qualify for one of these kits that that
takes away some of that con I believe
that that would take away some concern I
know that when this happened to me I
didn't think anybody would believe me or
anybody would do anything about it so I
didn't tell anybody for years but had I
known and had I known what my rights
were then it might not have you know
ended up uh with me treating it with a
couple extra tubs of uh of uh fudge
swirl ice cream that maybe I could have
dealt with it in the moment and uh
looking back to myself at that time of
life I really would have liked to know
what qualified and and if they would
have even listen to me at the emergency
room because I didn't even get to that
point because I didn't think that
anybody would listen or believe me and
know it's it's one of those issues too
we it's so
widespread it's so widespread that if we
can make sure that instead of dealing
with the consequences years and years
after you know I don't know how much of
um of alcoholism in women is just trying
to deal with this I know that you know I
didn't just treat it with a fudge soral
ice cream sometimes I treat it with the
martini too so um I just want to try and
get ahead of this and protect the people
that it's happening to now because for
those of us that it happened to in the
past you know that's water under the
bridge but what we need to do is look
forward and support people going forward
so that's why I've worked on this and I
think that even if it is a little bit
more work um I know representative Lynn
and I deal with lots and lots of
administrative rules that come through
Jael car um but it's it's
important representative Weber I just
want to acknowledge that
um we have all learned a lot since
2006 and I think there's been a huge
Evolution since this report was written
um I hope we will will continue to
evolve and one of the things that I
think is helpful in the the most in the
latest iteration of this is that it
allows for continued Evolution which was
not the case
before um and and it does so within the
rule ranking process which in itself is
glacial uh but um that that I think is
helpful but I I do want to acknowledge
because I see often
that we sometimes make laws that deal
with a situation that happened at some
point in the past and thank goodness we
have evolved past that point
already um in which case it's not always
necessary to make a law about it um
but that having been
said evolution is really important
so I recognize that I've evolved I'm
married so I'm not out in dating
situations I carry so I'm in less apt to
um sort of surprise situations but there
are a lot of people that haven't gone
through that process and are now in that
you know in that first emerging
butterfly stage and even though we may
have evolved past it unfortunately the
society hasn't evolved past sexual
assault I I look forward to that day I'm
not sure it'll happen but I look forward
I was talking about treatment options
rather than other
things um we actually are at um I don't
know if it would make sense for us to
recess this work session so that we can
begin the hearing on the non gerain
Amendment um because it's now 10:30 so
we're eligible to do that um and then
once we have this when we have an
appropriate time then we can um recess
what we're doing in order to come back
to the work session we I believe we have
to recess to a Time certain but you go
check with the clerk okay and now we
have the amendment but if we have an
amendment and a number I think we're
good to go perfect
yes um that was um the Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence
thank you and as I pass this down I will
move Amendment uh 2023 2448 H to House
Bill 37 8 is there a second a second
thank
you
okay um and as we were drafting it um it
retained the language just that reflects
what is the existing right um it's on
page on lines 12 through 14 there is the
existing right that you can refuse
elements of the test kit um and so I had
tried to remove that language because it
was one of those concerns of the
Coalition that's one where I felt like
we were going a little further than we
needed since it was an existing right um
but that actually got retained in
drafting so it would include the right
not to be prevented from or charged for
receiving a medical examination
including any individual element or
elements of the kit which is already
allowed because you can you can refuse
any
section perfect and it looks like we
have I believe we have what we have need
here so with that um I will pull up our
list of who is here and then call the
role I guess you have the list right
there representative Lon is a yes
representative
kushman yes representative
Palmer yes representative McDonald yes
representative Weber yes representative
nut upam yes fantastic that is six to
zero uh the amendment passes and I will
move ought to pass as amended by uh 2023
2448 8 you have a second
second and I will call the role on this
um representative Lon is a yes
representative kushman yes
representative
Palmer yes representative McDonald yes
Weber yes representative n upam yes and
it passes 6 to zero and we'll be dealing
with this later on today thank you so
much for your time and thank you so much
for working with us and getting to the
best bill that this could be so thank
you and with that I'll close the work
session on House Bill 36 378 I keep
missing up mixing up that Center number
um and then I will open the public
hearing on the non- derain amendment to
House Bill
am I correct that this is a full full
committee work session yes this is a
full this is a full committee work
session full full Committee hearing
hearing yes the previous was a work
session so it was our option to
recognize people to speak this is a
hearing where we're intentionally here
to listen to the public just wanted to
be sure that it was clear that the
entire committee was par just to explain
I've asked representative Leon to chair
this hearing because I'm a co-sponsor of
the
amendment than
you
okay okay Seth you can sit here for this
one while before he switches back
for
real
thank you madam chair if and since it's
a hearing um can you introduce it from
the um the seat over there I think
that's what we're supposed to do for a
hearing thank you and then I'll take a
pink card from you after you do that as
well just to keep all of our paperwork
in a
row
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is Gary Merchant representing
Selvin district 6 which is Claremont in
Cen
I come before the committee to introduce
an amendment to House Bill
580 and basically there was in original
Bill an addition to RSA
232 which was
32A and in speaking with the clerk and
the
speaker what they said was because we're
changing the fundamental part of 32
which was the strike the ground grounds
for which a person could um object to it
a parent or Guardian which was not part
of the original bill that would trigger
the non- gerain hearing which we're
having today so I bring before the
committee this amendment which was to
allow for vision
screening which was part of the physical
exam which is in RSA
232 at the same time to broaden
the ability for a parent or Guardian to
object to the physical exam which would
include div vision
screening so that's the reason for the
amendment to you folks today um it's if
you go back and look at the original
bill it's really truncated it
immensely um to a very small change in
the RSA underlying the physical
examination for a child um just a little
bit of a side note during the the
hearing on the subcommittee I was kind
of confused because I took the word
pupil to mean
student I sorry for I exam and not the
student themselves so we got off a
little bit of a tangent but that's not
the case
today thank you are there any
questions from the committee thank you
very much representative I'll bring up a
pink card thank you um and uh Curtis
Barry would you like to
speak
thank you madam chair good morning
members of the committee my name is
Curtis Barry I I'm here this morning on
behalf of the New Hampshire Optometric
Association which represents roughly 180
Doctors of Optometry here in the state
um I did not check off support or uh
oppose on the pink card primarily
because it's awful hard to oppose a
concept where we're encouraging more
Vision screenings for students um on the
other hand having discussions with both
members of the
association um representative Merchant
um I'm not sure on behalf of the
association what this particular
Amendment accomplishes uh you may recall
the public hearing which was many months
ago uh the association opposed the bill
as introduced for a variety of reasons
which don't need to go into um and I
know that the subcommittee made some
efforts to um send the bill in a
direction of encouraging a comprehensive
eye examination which is what the
association is all about a vision
screening has its place uh but it can
it's not Diagnostic in nature it
captures a fraction of vision or ey
health problems that a vision screening
will and a vision screening if there is
a problem identified you would need to
refer that student to
a comprehensive eye exam anyway or to
get a prescription um not sure what the
benefit of this particular amendment is
um I've committed to representative
Merchant if the committee so desires to
send the built inum study I've committed
that the Optometric Association would
provide resources both from our end and
the American Optometric Association
which is vastly more than than we have
including a lot of studies and a lot of
ideas so I'm happy to answer questions
Madam chair just please keep in mind I'm
not a doctor
thank you and I appreciate you being
here today are there any questions from
the
committee representative
kushman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question certainly um
so I would you agree that there's at
least some benefit of um the encouraging
language for a screening that then could
trigger the referrals and that would
increase the exams especially ones that
are needed and not you know screening
every or doing an exam on every child
when not be necessary thank you um yes
and no again there's there's benefit to
encouraging parents to have their
students or their children's eyes
checked certainly um in our opinion
though given the fact that unless I'm
missing something vision screening is
already part
of the the physical exam that the
child's going to go through and that
there are numerous school districts
where um optometrists opthalmologists in
conjunction with Lions Club provide
vision screenings
um I would look at this almost
as providing a false sense of security
in that oh the school district requires
my vision screening they're asking to to
ensure that I did get a vision screening
my kids's eyes are probably Al okay when
in fact the vision screening can Miss A
whole host of other conditions that
vision screening just doesn't
capture thank you for the
question thank you are there other
questions from the
committee saying none thank you so much
thank
you um is there anybody else here to
speak on the non-gain amendment to House
Bill
580 um with that I will call the hearing
on on the non gerain amendment to House
Bill 580 to a close um and we can
Shuffle our seats because uh we'll be
eligible to start our exec session in
two minutes thank you very
much
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
eight bills that we are going to be
considering an executive session this
morning uh before we do that however I
wish you I'd ask you to please join me
in the Pledge of
Allegiance Pledge of Allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible liberty and
justice for
all thank you
everyone I want to um welcome the um
individual substituting this morning we
have we have four substitutes and we
appreciate them being here I also want
to thank representative Murphy for
filling in for our clerk representative
Bill King who who uh is out of state
today so with that uh let's get onto the
business of the of the day uh first bill
for us to consider is a house bill
264 and representative land do you have
a
motion um yes I would move
itl okay representative uh Seth King I'd
like to second that motion okay would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Lon um yes thank you Mr
chairman um the this bill is about
changing your birth certificate to
reflect um current current things um I
truly believe that a birth certificate
is a record of your conditions at Birth
and we have many many other documents
which are better suited to proving
identity today it's a matter more of
proving your identity and having these
other documents as opposed to carrying
around a birth certificate as your proof
of who you are um in in the current day
um as far as as far as um
as far as current use of birth
certificates I believe that it is
absolutely critical for being able to
prove that you were born here and you're
a citizen for purposes like voting but
beyond that um we're pretty much trying
to use a document that trying to use a
document for more than it was originally
intended and therefore while I
appreciate I I appreciate the the
desires of the community I want to move
away from using birth certificates as a
current form of identity for anything
other than citizens ship and that's why
I moved um as
itl okay again we're discussing HB 264
the Motions itl representative Canon not
to put you on the spot but I I suspect
you might have some strong feelings
about
this well I appreciate representative
Leon's U position currently the
documents that we're using a birth
certificate driver's license and
passports there are no additional
options in the US
or in other countries so uh I proposed
this bill um to provide a change for
those individuals who want to be
documented correctly on their birth
certificate um which we already do this
just simplifies the process otherwise uh
an individual wishing to change their
information would have to incur the cost
of going to court and getting a Justice
to make the decision um with it and
still requiring the same information
that's proposed in this is a statement
from the doctor uh indicating that this
individual will be living their life as
the gender they identify as so it's a
simple one time only
um not require them to go to court to
get a Jud judicial decision uh but if
they want to change it at a future date
it would require the same process that
we currently
have thank you other
discussion representative Weber I just
wanted to point out that I think was
sort of understood in what
representative Canon said we do change
birth certificates for children who are
adopted uh to conform those to the
realities of their life and we do that
without having to think about a whole
different kind of document I don't think
that this is a huge departure from what
we're already doing I think it's an
affirming step that I am very much in
favor of thank you so I will be opposing
uh itl and hoping for not to pass motion
thank you representative uh Merchant
thank you Mr
chair this basically does not change the
outcome all is doing is talking about
the
process basically if someone goes to the
court today they can change the birth
certificate
accordingly that's the end result all
this is doing is changing the journey on
which one goes to get there and making
it more simplistic and easier to obtain
than what we have today so I want to go
back to the outcome doesn't change it's
only the process the path we choose to
get there thank you representative Lon
um thank you Mr chairman um I had a
question for representative Weber when a
child is adopted does that mean that the
parent on the birth certificate is
changed I'm curious how adoption would
change the birth
certificate I believe that a new perhaps
um
representative um oh please help me ly
Lynn might have more insight but I
believe that an entirely new document is
issued because uh the child has been
adopted they have new parents they have
a new name and we make those those
changes on an amended birth
certificate I I don't know the answer to
that question sorry to have put you on
the spot and I'm really sorry about my
inability to remember names for which I
apologize to every two attorneys here
and neither can answer a legal question
this is not good not in this state your
honor my experience is also from out of
the state but it it is my understanding
that they do change the birth
certificates for in adoption
proceedings presed L on I had no
idea
um that's news to me other discussion
representative
Shapero yes thank you Mr chair
um you know people have said already
that this doesn't change the fact that
we can change birth certificates it just
changes the process of how it's done and
it streamlines that process and I know
we've heard this bill or this kind of
bill for years now and one of the things
that always stood out for me was people
talking about the subjectivity of the
process as it stands now that um some
people might be be go before a judge who
reads the law one way and some people
another way and so that this will reduce
or eliminate that subjectivity about
when names are changed and when it
doesn't go through Mr chairman could I
call a
caucus
um great um so I will vote um I I will
vote against I feel thank you is a brief
one representative L I think five
minutes three minutes five minutes
something like okay all right brief take
a brief
recess
okay thank you for your patience um any
other discussion on this um on this
motion or this
bill representative kushman thank you I
just wanted to follow up on that thought
um about the birth certificate change
process for children in adoption
proceedings and even
um uh like um uh yeah it's the only
adoption those those require going
through the court um you know there is a
and I understand there's the issue with
the judges and and discretion and they
say that the laws are vague often but um
if that's that's truly a problem then we
need to look at those statutes that
govern how the judges make those
decisions and I don't think that we
should be um you know allowing you know
Vital Records like this to be changed at
a lower threshold than we would for
adoptions so I will be voting
um I will be voting against this Bill
thank you thank you other
discussion right saying none the motion
is to itl on House Bill 264 I'll ask the
clerk to call the
r representative leam
yes representative kushman yes
representative Lynn yes representative
ative kofalt yes representative
Reid
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative veril
yes representative palov yes
representative
Weber
no representative McKay
no representative
fedus
no representative Canon no
representative representative Nutter
upam representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant
no uh representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no representative
Priest No and representative McDonald
yes
the vote is 10 to 10
okay okay I suspect there's another
Motion in the offering
or I move to I move out to pass on House
Bill 264 I would second the motion
motions are made and seconded would you
like to speak to your motion
representative
Canon yeah your microphone's off by I
believe I stated that prior to this
great thank you any other discussion
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
264 seeing no other discussion when the
clerk is ready we'll
proceed representative Lon
no Representative kushman
no representative Lynn no Representative
kofalt no representative Reed no
representative Seth King no
representative Missour no
Representative ril no Representative
palov no representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest yes
10 and me oh and
represent every clerk every clerk does
it I've done it um no I did it my second
time
too no
good 10 to
10 okay so um representative Weber are
you're the expert on this stuff but it
go to no recommendation correct it's my
understanding and I see our researcher
nodding her head I I don't think we have
to exhaust inter room study and the
other ones just so repres representative
Leon I understand you're doing the
majority I was well you're doing one
report right yes the itl and who's doing
the
uh the uh I believe representative Canon
is doing the other one I I will do that
thank you thank you very
much and again um this is do a die week
and I know I I know committee services
will be eternally grateful if we can get
things in by midweek am I correct
Christina on
that uh so that uh you know it's going
to be very busy at the end of the week
so so if you can get your reports in by
by tonight or tomorrow that would be
fantastic I still have to review them
and then I'll send them
over okay um moving on to House Bill
317 um recognize representative Lon um
thank you I'd like to move in expedient
to legislate on House Bill
317 okay do I have a second
representative Weber do you second
representative Weber seconds
representative Leon do you want to speak
to your motion uh yes thank you very
much Mr chairman um this was one of our
two bills that we retained on uh the
Bureau of development on the services
redesign program um we'll speak about
some of the other issues later however
when we had the assistant commissioner
of the Bureau of Developmental Services
U testified to us um we were very
comfortable when she stated that there
would be no work done uh moving towards
a two-tiered waiver system for the
developmental disabilities Community
prior to 2026 if at all um and given
that time frame and given that we got
that in testimony um the entire
subcommittee felt comfortable moving as
well as a prime sponsor felt comfortable
moving an expedient to legislate on this
bill uh because it's not needed at this
time great thank you other
discussion representative wber I would
add only that um all members members of
the communities affected uh
representatives of members of all
communities affected were very very
involved in this process and um I
believe that uh although things are not
fixed in any way shape or form uh they
felt that they were heard and we heard
them that this is no longer the route
that needs to be
pursued thank you
other
discussion seeing no other discussion
we'll I'll ask the clerk to call the
rooll the motion is um itl on House Bill
3177 representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative
Lynn yes yes representative kall yes
representative Reed yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative verm verv yes
representative palov yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay yes
representative fedus yes representative
Canon yes representative Nutter
upam representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest yes
representative McDonald yes thank
you9 okay uh if there's no objection
we'll put on
consent and representative L you're
doing the report yes thank you thank you
very much all right moving on House Bill
368 um representative Missour did you
have a motion yes thank you Mr chair I
would like to make a motion to move HB
368 to interm
study uh representative cofal do you
have a motion I will second that okay do
you want to speak to your motion
representative Missour yes thank you Mr
chair um after long discussions about it
in our subcommittee concerns arose over
the
unconstitutionality of it specifically
in regards to article 4 section two of
our constitution we need to do some some
more research on it and we voted three
to one in subcommittee to do
so okay other
discussion
representative
Canon you just turn your microphone
off um yes we did have a long discussion
uh I'm a firm believer that the uh the
area of the Constitution that's
discussed is extradition of individuals
for uh committing a crime in in a state
and the the intent of this particular
bill is to um provide uh transgender
care and services
before a crime has been committed in the
state that the family may have
left thank you other
discussion I'm seeing no other
discussion motion is um interim study
for House Bill
368 I'll ask the clerk to call rooll
Representative Leon yes representative
kushman yes representative Lynn yes
representative kofalt yes yes
representative
Reed yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative veril yes repres
representative palov yes representative
Weber no representative McKay no
Representative fedus no representative
Canon
no representative Nutter upam no
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no representative
Palmer no representative Priest No
representative McDonald
yes 10 to 10 okay the motion fails 10 to
10 is there another
motion yes Mr
chair yes go ahead representative
mour motion to
itl representative Mo representative
Missour moves itl is there a second I
will second that representative kofalt
second uh do you want to speak to your
motion representative
Missour yes I think we did we we
received a lot of feedback from our
community and our state on this subject
have you as you've seen the email
streaming in right and um and citizens
are constituents are concerned with the
potential of making New Hampshire a
sanctuary State um those are the words
that they are using for this bill and a
lot of them have done their research on
it um so I personally am going to listen
to the flood of messages I have received
about this even as we just walked in the
door today they were still flooding in
um so that's why I'm going with the itl
motion thank you other discussion
representative plaz
off uh I think uh this type of secession
move is very
questionable uh so I'm not comfortable
with passing it without further
study thank you representative Weber
sorry I wasn't sure you had your hand up
before quite all right um I'm going to
vote against an itl motion because I
think that
um
we have heard a great deal from both
sides of this particular question and I
think it is incredibly
important that we
support
those who are in the midst of a very
difficult journey and that we affirm the
rights of individuals and their parents
to make these decisions
and and
um get the treatments that they believe
they need in a caring and medically
sensitive
way okay representative Reed thank you
Mr chairman I don't you might want to
move your microphone closer to you I
don't think New Hampshire is a mecca for
gender affirming care or surgery um I
just don't don't
see why we should go here if people
aren't requesting service you know
surgeries and treatment from New
Hampshire to begin with and my other
concern is down the road um what is our
liability for um miners who come to New
Hampshire for surgery then down the road
feel they made an error could they come
back and sue our inst our hospitals
doctors and the state for treatment they
received as a minor thank you thank
you other discuss representative
Canon um I too also received many uh
requests to pass this
bill this bill does not change the
services we currently offer all New
Hampshire
families this bill would protect our
medical professionals
and and have the ability for them to
retain the information about the
services and care that they have
provided a family and the
patient uh no no more no less the the
thing that they would be protected from
would be uh the inquiry from out of
state for that information to be used to
prosecute a family for taking care of
their child um that is the simple
um part of this bill I know that people
have referred to it as a sanctuary Bill
if they want to stay here in New
Hampshire I would love to have them stay
it people from outside New Hampshire are
already coming to New Hampshire for care
we don't offer them anything else in
addition to what we currently Pro
provide our own residents so uh
it I would I'm not going to vote for itl
on this bill I'm G to F vote to pass it
thank you representative Leon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for that
um I am concerned about the idea of
doctors being subpoena from out of state
and that's why I had hoped we would be
able to work on an interim study on this
in order to address that um as the bill
stands I can't support it um in its
current state and that's the basis of my
position but I know that we've tried to
work together on this to get to
agreement even if that may not be
possible this time thank you
representative Lyn yeah you know it
strikes me that I I think I'm going to
support the itl because I really do
think this is a
bad this this addresses this issue in a
in what I think is an inappropriate way
I think that there is a real question
don't get me wrong I think there's a
real question whether a state could
could enact a law to prosecute somebody
for getting gender affirming care in
another state even if you're a citizen
in other words if I'm a citizen of tech
Texas and I come to New Hampshire to get
gender affirming care in New Hampshire
I'm not sure whether Texas could
prosecute me for that that might that
might be unconstitutional itself I don't
know the answer to that but if it is
constitutional for Texas to regulate
citizens of Texas getting out of state
gender affirming care then it seems to
me that it's really it really would be
making for New Hampshire to then say
we're not going to give you the
information even though you can legally
and constitutionally take action uh uh
you know against a citizen who gets
gender affirming care in another state
that just strikes me as that is sort of
be taking the position that New
Hampshire is going to be a sanctuary
that will not give that information and
I frankly there could be a
constitutional issue as to that also
whether New Hampshire could actually do
that assuming that it's legal for Texas
in my example to to make it to to to to
to prosecute somebody for getting gender
affirming care in another state I
frankly have S significant doubt that
Texas could do that in my example but if
they could then you know there's no I to
me there's no reason for New Hampshire
not to be not to cooperate and provide
that information so that's why I will be
voting I thank you other
discussion I'm seeing no other
discussion motion is itl on House Bill
36 8 I'll ask the clerk to call the
rooll representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Lynn
yes representative kofalt yes
representative Reed yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour
yes representative ril yes
representative palov yes representative
Weber no representative McKay no
Representative fedus no representative
Canon no representative Nutter upam
representative Shapiro no representative
Merchant no representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no representative
Priest No representative McDonald
yes 10 to 10 okay is there another
motion representative Canon I move out
to pass on House Bill 368 is there a
second second representative Weber
seconds representative Canon do you wish
to speak further on this
or you just shut your mic off again um
similar bills have passed in in other
states in the US uh this is a
continuation of the same to offer um a
place for people to feel safe to get
care for their transgender child and uh
and I want to vote on to pass thank you
other
discussion representative Missour I have
a question of Representative Canon can
you tell us which states those
are I know for sure California has and
I'm not sure what the additional states
are but I know that at least four states
have other
discussion representative
palazov uh I want to say if you want to
make this
radical step of removing New Hampshire
from the union policing framework we
need at least to study it and next year
there will be some legislation on to
create a commission to study processes
like that so I urge my colleagues not to
hurry with this Bill thank you thank
you other discussion representative
merant thank you Mr chair
I think this bill fundamentally goes to
the heart of it critical issue one it
protects the sanctimony of the patient
pH
relationship which we hold sacred in our
country and that physician providers and
Healthcare and so forth first Do no harm
and if we want to protect that I think
we need to have the protection for that
number two we also talk about the
sanctity of the parent and a parent have
the ability to make rights and decisions
for the children we hold that dear to us
as well all this bill in my opinion is
doing is protecting those two
fundamental beliefs that we have in our
country the right to have medical care
based upon what you think is right
between you and the position and not
having the state getting involved with
that and two the right of the parent to
guide the Journey of their child and not
have the state get in the middle of that
either so I see this really as a bill as
protecting those fundamental freedoms
that we've come to enjoy so dearly in
our country thank you thank you other
discussion representative
Canon I have a list of states that have
passed laws similar to this uh
California Colorado Illinois Maryland
New Mexico and
Minnesota thank
you and represent
chapero thank you Mr chair I
would piggyback on um what
representative Merchant said um which is
to say that this bill will also protect
um privacy and confidentiality um which
this state values tremendously and which
is part of the whole Foundation of
medical care that people will have um
confidentiality in getting that care and
their records will be
protected thank
you other discussion representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman um I agree
about the necessity to protect the
privacy of medical records um I'm just
concerned about doing it on a case-by
casee basis um I actually do have a bill
in for next year that would strengthen
the protections of medical records and
I'm hopeful that we can address
holistically how that relationship needs
to be protected in that manner but I
think doing it Case by case is less
effective than overall
thank you I'm glad that we all share the
the respect for patient privacy and the
doctor patient relationship it's always
good when we have agreement even when
there's some areas where we do have
disagreement on how to do
things other discussion representative
Shapero I I would agree generally with
representative Leon um but I think the
reason for singling this issue out is
because there is talk from other states
about Prosecuting people who go to
another state I I I don't know if any
states are doing that um but it's
certainly um in the public discourse
that that's being talked about both for
abortion care and for this kind of
care other representative kosman thank
you Mr chairman um my my concerns are
not only with the constitutionality of
it um but also the complexities um that
might come from this bill being passed
um consider cases where um parental
rights are terminated for one parent or
where um they're in the middle of court
and someone takes the kid to a state um
like ours if we had this pass and um you
know what's going to be the legal
Fallout for that and if later one of the
parents ends up suing then they have no
right to get any of the medical
information on their child if this bill
is passed um and I don't think that that
would be be right either um so I think
it's just too complex of legal issues
that haven't really been parsed out um
to the Fine detail and uh I think that
we can sit back and we can see how other
states are doing this um and
additionally I think it flies in the
face of like um the the rights states
are meant to do things a little bit
differently you know we all have
different cultures different populations
and one state may do things um different
ly than another and I think that trying
to prosecute um someone for some in one
state for something they did in another
state whether it's an abortion or um you
know a transexual um a gender genital
surgery um you know I don't I don't see
how that's going to apply and I don't
agree on principle in making laws that
um would stop another state from
enforcing their own laws thank
you thank you other discussion
saying no other discussion the motion is
ought to pass on House Bill 368 I'll ask
collector call the
r representative Lon no Representative
kushman no representative Lynn no
Representative kofalt no representative
Reed no representative Seth King no
representative Missour no representative
reveal no representative pelov no
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon yes representative
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest yes
representative McDonald
no
10 10 okay so that house bill fee 68
will go on to the house without
recommendation um representative Missour
I assume you'll be doing the report on
itl yes thank you Mr CH representative
Canon you'll do the out to pass we don't
need one for an uh interim study right
or do
we if we don't need one we won't do one
or do we need
one um we can choose to have um there's
there's a different position so we could
either choose to have itl or interim
study but we're choosing to do itl okay
yeah you can't you can't have both we we
don't normally have three okay so just
so uh the the choice is up to the the
group as to which one of those they will
choose okay so we'll just do those two
then okay great thank you thank you okay
next next up is a house bill
378 and uh representative Lon do you
have a motion um yes thank you Mr
chairman um I move that we adopt
amendment
2023-24 48h to House Bill
378 okay is there a second second
representative weo seconds
representative Lon do you want to speak
to your motion um yes thank you Mr
chairman uh this is a bill that came
about because even though we have laws
that establish right for survivors of
sexual assault not everybody who is
involved in the care and treatment is
fully aware of this and unfortunately we
have had survivors uh turned away and
turned away and made unable to um
actually have their rights protected um
we had walked through the different
processes of how to do this we had
originally looked to put some of this
into the statutes um to take the best
practices that are in the um that are
already created by the department of
Justice in order to have um these these
policies and procedures um with looking
on feedback that we had from the
Coalition against Dom Domestic and
Sexual Violence and feedback from others
um what we realized that was the best
and cleanest approach was to charge the
Department of Justice to make um summary
document or documents for sexual assault
survivors and those who provide care for
them or interact with them so that they
can have those pertinent parts of the
rights so that uh Survivor would know
whether or not they would be eligible to
have the have the test kit done in order
to pot hopefully bring Justice to the
perpetrator um one of the areas that
we've heard about the challenges of
Prosecuting cases is that people don't
AR always have the evidence that they
need and so this does also include that
it's helpful to bring the clothes you
were wearing because bringing the
clothes that you wearing um is one of
those parts that will help you get some
of that evidence so by dovetailing into
to the existing protocol and simply
adding an additional um an additional
document that summarizes the 100 plus
documents already available it makes it
more accessible especially for survivors
when they're trying to go from being a
victim to a Survivor and this was
adopted and there was a um this
amendment was adopted and they ought to
pass recommend as amended recommendation
pass the subcommittee 6 to zero this
morning okay thank you other discussion
my representative
pmer I just have have thank you I just
have a sort of question uh in general
which is that I know the Coalition had
some concerns because they had not much
time to look at this am I correct in
assuming that they would be able to have
input to the justice department and how
they set up these rules and therefore
could maybe elay some of the concerns
they might have that way representative
Leon um thank you by doing it through
administrative rules the Coalition
anybody here on this committee any
citizen the police departments and
anybody involved in this process will be
able to participate in the hearings as
these are created and um guide and shape
the document to make sure that it best
reflects the needs of the different
communities thank you representative
pazo I'm sorry then representative Weber
go ahead um just uh represent uh could
you briefly explain uh how it changes
the the regional Bill and for example if
I remember correctly the original bill
was trying to expand cases when uh rape
protocol could be used if somebody is
drugged or otherwise
impacted um thank you the original
request for the bill did not seek to
expand it but the way that it was worded
it did um one of the other areas that
that was improved in this amendment is
um is making clear that if somebody is
reporting an attempted rape that you can
that you can figure out if a misdemeanor
sexual assault happened so perhaps that
they were drugged and while they didn't
get to the ultimate fulfillment of rape
they were groped in the process that is
a crime that's misdemeanor sexual
assault and that's already provided for
in the protocols uh because we do so
much and we rely so much on the sex
offender registry that making sure that
even those who do not reach their full
success in committing these sex crimes
do get on that registry then they're not
going to be able to be a Boy Scout
leader they're not going to be able to
be a teacher they're not going to be
able to volunteer in a school because
they're a sex offender so taking even
these cases where a victim is able a
Survivor is able to get away and making
sure that we provide them the rights
that are already established is key um
we just cleaned up the language to
instead of putting the cases before the
statutes we said any individual who
asserts that they've been subject to an
offense under the aggravated felonius
felonius and misdemeanor sex assault and
then say in including but not limited to
and putting it into terms that people
can better understand um specifically so
that it does not expand the scope uh
because that was just one of the issues
in drafting especially it's one of the
reasons why this needs to be so clear it
needs to be so clear because if you've
experienced this you sometimes look at
things and don't don't you read it the
way that you think you're reading it but
we need to make sure that the
information is there when I read
attempted rape I thought it was very
clear that it was the misdemeanor sexual
assault um but we need to make sure that
the correct information is in people's
hands sorry for going on it's a
sensitive
subject thank you representative wber
thank you and I would like to thank
everybody involved for the work that has
progressed from where we started to hear
um I think that the um amendment is uh a
huge Improvement in Clarity and and in
providing information to survivors
without getting in the way of medical
treatment or um and and and it may
enhance the ability to
prosecute uh all of which is good and it
also leaves anybody who has been
assaulted with the
choices of deciding their own fate uh
rather than leaving it to other people
which is really important uh I am going
to vote for the amendment and for the
ought to pass as amended I do recognize
that the Coalition only saw the final
draft which was an attempt to address
concerns that they had with the last
draft uh recently and they may want to
check with um uh other other folks who
are not represented here today and there
is time between now and the time we vote
on it on the house floor if things come
to our
attention uh we'll deal with whatever
that is at the time but uh for now I
think that this is a good effort in the
right direction so I will be supporting
it representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that
representative Weber um we we would make
sure want to make sure that any of that
is done well ahead of time so that we
can we can speak together if there are
any concerns this amendment came through
so late because we had requested
feedback by a certain time period so we
could handle it before the other bills
um we just want to make sure that we're
not in a last minute situation because
this is happening the we're going to be
on the floor just before the holidays
and I'm sorry I don't want to be Rel
reliving my sexual assault over
Christmas so I hope that if there is
anything it's it's done almost
immediately so that we can deal with
this and put it to bed before the
holidays because I'm going to eat enough
dessert already I really don't need to
be eating my
feelings other
discussion okay thank you um so the
motion is out to pass on Amendment 2023
hyen
2448 I'll ask the clerk to call the
rooll representative Lam yes
representative kushman yes
representative Lynn yes representative
covalt yes representative Reed yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative reveal yes representative
palov yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative shapir
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest yes
representative McDonald yes 20 to
nothing passes 20 to nothing if there's
no objection we'll put that on the
consent calendar um could I move a to
pass as amended by Amendment 2248 H okay
motion is now uh to um move or to pass
is amended is there a second second
representative Weber seconds
would you like to speak to the motion or
are we ready we could probably call the
r okay is there any other discussion
before we do
so okay when the Clark is
ready representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Lynn yes representative
kofalt yes representative Reed yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative veril yes representative
POF yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative n Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative
Merchant yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes and
representative
yes represented McDonald yes 20 nothing
okay and that's what that'll obviously
go on the consent calendar which is what
I should have said could have held off
on but uh before um but there's no
objection okay moving on House Bill 580
is next representative merchant do you
wish to make a
motion yes i' like to make a motion to
interim study on House Bill 580 okay
representative kofalt and I will second
that motion
representative merchant do you wish to
speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair in talking
to
the lobbyist if you will for the
association of automet and also folks
within the field of Opthalmology there's
tremendous intent here which I think we
should work on I don't think the bill is
ready for Prime Time particular with the
amendment that we proposed this morning
as far as non Germain I would like to
take the opportunity to work with them
on a interim study basis to begin to
understand how we can draft something
that would be more appropriate if you
will for the um children of our state
going forward thank you thank you other
discussion seeing
none okay if there's no other discussion
we will I'll ask the clerk to call the
RO motion is interim study on House Bill
580 representative leam yes
representative kushman yes
representative Lynn yes representative
kofalt yes representative Reed yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative reveal yes representative
POF yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay yes
representative fedus yes representative
Canon yes representative nutam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest yes
representative McDonald yes
20 okay um passes 20 to nothing if
there's no objection we'll put that in
consent representative Merchant you'll
do a report on interim study yes thank
you okay next up House Bill 608
representative L do you wish to make a
motion uh yes thank you Mr chairman I
would like to move interim study on
House Bill
608 okay do I have a second
representative wo seconds representative
lean do you want to speak to your motion
um yes thank you Mr chairman this bill
came to us ahead of a lot of monumental
changes in the Bureau of Developmental
Services um it sought to put a pilot
program in before changes including to
the um the reimbursement model model um
sorry into the direct billing model um
we had
consider sorry one second uh so it it
sought to make changes um to have a
pilot program to make sure that all of
this was going to proceed and that um hi
hiccups could be minimized um the
department has been undertaking the
herculan task of transitioning over to a
direct billing method and while they are
putting in a tremendous amount of man
hours there continue to be challenges to
this um challenges that we heard from
the provider Community
challenges um where with the the time
frame for payments there's the question
about fiscal solvency for some of the
providers being able to continue to pay
what they need to the people that
provide services to the developmental
community and um after this there's
still going to be some other changes
there'll be a switch over to the
electronic visit verification where the
providers need to bring a cell phone
with them and check in that they are
providing care um and that they are for
those Services that's going to be fun in
a state like ours where on our caucus
several of us dropped off because of
internet connection issues so making
sure that it's undertaken on a more
stepwise fashion uh to at least let a
couple people go up to bat first before
it goes out to the entire Community
would be helpful and what I'm hearing
right now is that the department will
will is willing to work with just a
couple area agencies to iron out the
wrinkles for the electronic visit
verification that's the last remaining
one that's impacting our federal funding
because we're already paying some fines
but there are additional changes as well
that are coming under the A&M um report
and some others so this is an area where
it's quite possible that we'll need to
bring some legislative Solutions next
session to see what's happened how we
can better support the Deport Department
how we can better support the providers
and how we can better support the
individuals served by the system um and
so this is one of those areas where
we're going to do an interim study and
I'm also hopeful that we'll name a
subcommittee today with those members
from the subcommittee um working on this
bill so that we can move forward and
just make sure that we're hearing from
everybody involved and just make sure
that this is proceeding because uh we
never want anybody to slip through the
cracks and if you have a family who's
struggling with supporting their
developmentally disabled child or even
an adult with developmental disabilities
who relies on these state provided
Services you know if we're going to help
anybody this is who we need to help so I
think having some attention and bringing
the stakeholders back together to
discuss things is going to give us the
best solution moving forward um and
that's why our subcommittee recommended
interim study 6 to zero and wanted to
stay involved in this process okay thank
you representative Weber and I will just
add I I think it's really implied by
what was said but uh the what became
clear as we talked in the subcommittee
was we had the bill which really no
longer addressed the issues that are
real severe and ongoing but the fact
that we were having the
conversations allowed better
communication between all parties and I
think it was the sense of the
subcommittee members that we want to
have ongoing conversations we thought
about referring this to Health and Human
Services oversight for those we thought
about the appointment of an ad hoc
special committee by the chair uh but we
thought that as long as those of us who
were on the subcommittee had already
been uh listening to the concerns and
dealing with the issues that uh we were
committed to go on doing that and we
thought that this might be the uh best
way to ensure continuity of that
conversation going
forward thank you other
discussion seeing none okay the motion
is interim study on House Bill 608 FN
I'll ask the clerk to call the all
representative Leon yes representative
kushman yes representative Lynn yes
representative kofalt yes yes
representative Reed yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative veril yes representative
POF yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter
upam representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest yes
representative McDonald yes
20 okay again if there's no objection
we'll put it that on the consent
calendar and representative L you'll do
the report yes thank you um thank you
yes and I will need to run up to house
committee services to get the print out
for 619 so I don't know if we wanted to
move to the Senate bill before we went
did 69 okay that's
fine there's no objection we'll we'll
move to Senate Bill 236 and actually
does do people have a copy of that
Amendment the
um I don't know if that was printed out
maybe you want to get both amendments
yeah I I'll see if that's up there okay
do we know whose name that would be
under M and representative Weber okay
I'll go see if that's there and just for
everybody's information all it did this
was the bill that we actually voted on
last time and then representative Murray
actually read it and realized that the
reporting date would have passed so um
it just am it just amends the reporting
date right representative Shapiro um I
would like to request that when we get
the amendment for 619 that we have a
break of five minutes or so so that we
can actually read through it carefully
sure we can do
that okay well uh we only have those two
bills left so why don't we take a brief
recess while we're we're waiting for the
amendments to arrive and we'll basically
extend the recess uh after we get the
amendment so you can read them I think
we need a time for
returning why don't we why don't we say
we'll be back at noon does that work for
everyone pH gives me a chance to catch
up doing well
trying
like to
reconvene uh before we uh get to House
Bill 619 and the amendment in the Bill
itself I do want to address uh we
referred um House Bill 608 to interim
study and I would like to appoint the
subcommittee that has already done a lot
of work on that to the interim study
committee which would be representative
Lon as chairman representative Nagel
representative fedus representative
Weber representative kofalt and
representative Merchant thank you and
would that be an ad hoc committee to
work while we while we move forward yes
yes thank you could you just State those
again oh sure I've forgotten one okay
sure uh representative Lon would be
chairman and representative Nagel
representative fedus yourself
representative Weber representative kof
fa and representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair representative Merchant yes
is there going to be uh on the house
bill 580 for interim study are we going
to have another selection of members of
this
committee uh representative CL did you
have something sorry my this was an ad
hoc committee ad hoc subcommittee to
continue what we've done on House Bill
608 ad hoc it's it's not an ad hoc
committee it's an interim study
committee so it's now official we don't
have to have both the interim study
doesn't go to the house floor it it it
will have to go to the house floor yes
okay um can but can we have an ad hoc
committee so that we're not waiting
until January so that we can hear if we
need to before December I don't I don't
I mean you the chair can appoint
anything he wants to appoint so there's
no reason not to but I didn't see any
reason to uh take it up again before
January there is no house session before
January correct um just in case there
was a necessity to meet if there were
any other changes to the process um
whether things are going better or going
worse with the direct billing and if
there's any anything that would be
helped by having us meet although you
can name ad hoc committees even out of
these meetings so I just wanted to make
sure that we weren't uh missing anything
minut it's far as the subcommittee
meeting or the ad hoc committee meeting
whatever term you want to use that I
would leave that up to the discretion of
the committee members and and yourself M
representative Merchant yeah I'm not I
didn't mean to ignore you no I I want to
be clear about if it's
a signed subcommittee of this committee
then it has I believe look at the um
researcher it has to go through notice
and also public hearing if it's an ad
hoc group it doesn't require notice in
the calendar and I think you can also
meet via
Zoom no first of all no no subcommittee
of this body can meet via Zoom because
it's not in our
rules even an ad hoc no there is no
authorization and the only thing that
speaks to it is Masons which says if
there is no specific authorization you
can't do it so that's where we
are for this
body
the house not the Senate the Senate has
different
rules so we
can't okay and and yes any subcommittee
of this committee is subject to RSA 91a
so there has to be
notice uh but there doesn't have to be a
hearing it could be a public meeting
where
people um go and it's not necessarily a
hearing it could just be a work session
it in fact a subcommittee could not have
a hearing that's my
understanding
so I guess I'm I'm trying to
understand if we're having a work
session or an ad hoc
session my concept would be it would be
like any other interim study committee I
have seen interim studies done by
subcommittees that did nothing
I have seen interim studies that have
been worked on only by the full
committee I have seen interim studies
that have been worked by a very small
subcommittee very intensively it depends
on the bill but we can do any of those
under the interm study rubric so I don't
see why one needs unless there was some
kind of emergency that came up in which
case the chair could appoint an ad hoc
committee to deal with it but
following the House vote it's an interim
study bill you appoint a subcommittee if
that seems good to you which it has
because you have and and we just go on
as we were okay thank you representative
Merchant does that answer your question
or temporarily okay all right well let
me know when you need a more permanent
answer
um okay um
so moving on from 608 uh next bill up
for our consideration today is House
Bill
619 and U yes um representative L did
you have your hand up or oh should I
make a
motion oh representative kushman either
one yes um thank you Mr chairman I oh
sorry
sorry thank you Mr chairman um I would
move that
we adopt Amendment
I can't find
it 2023 hyen 2451 H that's the one okay
thank you and uh representative Seth
King did you have a second for that a
second OTP okay uh representative excuse
me that's not OTP it's on the
amendment yes of the amendment sorry
right uh representative kushman did you
want to speak to your motion yes thank
you
um so through the work of the
subcommittee um on this bill we found
some common ground um toward the
beginning of the work session um where
there was some agreement about um
perhaps that the surgeries need a pause
um towards the end of the work session
it seemed that um opinions changed a
little bit differently and we were not
able to find consensus um however this
amendment here is a result of that work
um and it is it has chiseled the bill
down greatly um you'll see on uh the
first section is the statements of are
the statements of
purpose um second section on page
two um are the well beginning on page
two um are the
definitions and then we come down and um
we have the prohibition of genital
gender reassignment surgery on minor
um so these are specific to the
reconstructive surgeries on the
genitalia of
minors um for gender reassignment
purposes there are exemptions there um
or it it it specifically um states that
what are not prohibited are those um
malformation malignancy injury or
physical disease
procedures um and male
circumcision um so this would just bring
House Bill 619 it replaces the entire
text of that bill um and prohibits
genital gender surgeries on any
individuals under the years of 18 in the
state of New Hampshire thank
you okay other
discussion representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman um first I
would like to um
um voice my appreciation for um the
chair representative Leon and for the um
representative Leon kushman and mour who
brought this amendment I think it
um it it obviously it greatly narrowed
the thrust of the bill um but also it
was done with
um a great deal of respect and I think
it allowed us to have a a committee
discussion which um was
really you know people where people
disagreed but it was respectful and
nobody was um I don't know how to put it
exactly but um being overtly
discriminatory towards a group of people
and so I I just want to voice my
appreciation for that
um in terms of the actual Amendment um
I would say that I'm uncomfortable with
what I see as kind of a slant in the
Preamble or the purpose of the bill um
specifically on page two where it talks
about
um adolescent genital gender
reassignment surgery generally lacks
both adequate information for informed
consent well I you know I think that
there are many medical um associations
that would dis agree with that um but
that wasn't put in here and then it goes
on to say that it involves a high risk
of coercion for parental consent when
parents believe that they're faced with
a choice between child committing
suicide or consenting to their child's
gender assignment surgeries I think
we've heard a lot about
um the problem with suicidality with
people who have um um this kind of
dysphoria um maybe that's overstated as
well but I think this is just purely
conjecture and without any data to
support it that you know that parents
are going along with I mean first of all
the surgeries aren't happening in New
Hampshire and second of all we it's just
conjecture to say that their that
parents are basically being blackmailed
into agreeing to their kids getting care
because they're being told by
professionals that their kids are going
to commit suicide otherwise was um so to
me that that's a slant that I feel
uncomfortable
with regardless um I am going to vote
against adopting the amendment I just
think that we've heard over and over
again that these surgeries are not done
um that all care is done with the um
participation and consent of parents and
families and
um so I can't understand why we are
picking one group of people to limit
care that um that is not happening and
um because we're doing that um not only
is it interfering with um the patient um
physician
um relationship and legislating medical
care but it also feels discriminatory to
me because we're picking this one group
to set limitations on
so I'm going to vote against it I think
it was a good process talking about it
I'm sure it will go on um but I'm going
to vote against it representative Leon
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for that representative Shapiro um when
we had had the public hearing on the
non- derain amendment uh Dartmouth
Hitchcock had told us that the genital
gender reassignment surgeries were well
researched um unfortunately the data
that were provided um did not provide
any information about genital gender
surgeries the information that was
provided was for puberty blockers um in
a search of the data and search of the
evidence looking at clinical trials.gov
looking at every s single repository I
know of and I've researched a couple
things um there are no data that show
the safety or efficacy um I I could not
find any studies that spoke to the
genital gender reassignment surgeries
and because there are no data um it yet
there is is an overwhelming push to tell
people that it is safe and effective
without the actual clinical the clinical
evidence and clinical studies in order
to support that that's where I am highly
concerned that it's hard to give
informed consent if you don't know what
the risks are um this is an area that is
very emotional because it is so
important to the core being of so many
people um and that's why I'm very very
concerned that having well-respected
institutions state that it's well
researched but
being unable to provide that
research really makes me concerned for
the parents who simply hear well
researched and go along with it even
though that they're unable to provide it
and then as far as speaking to the fact
about whether or not it's happening in
New Hampshire um we were not able to get
airm no that it was happening but when
you look at Medical Practice especially
areas of emerging Technologies and
emerging therapies a lot of times if you
hire in a doctor or a surgeon who's
doing a procedure then suddenly that
practice pops up around them um this is
a growing area and we don't know if any
of our hospitals are looking to move
into that area um I'm very troubled
about the lack of evidence and the lack
of response with any data to support the
safety of this and that's why I believe
that until there are such data it's
important to hold off and wait till the
age of majority so that um just so that
you can make that decision and legally
you're not bringing anybody else into it
as well well um I I don't know if you've
heard the parents being told would you
rather have a dead son or Alive daughter
that I would do anything for my kids I I
would do absolutely anything for my kids
and hearing that phrase would have me do
absolutely anything it I would do
anything so it's that's the concern
that's why it says a high- risk it
doesn't say that the parents are being
coerced but when you have language like
that I mean I'm getting the emotional
reaction now you know it's you protect
your kids and and the parents believe
that when they're told that it's well
researched and they're told about the
potential catastrophic risk of not
having that surgery they may consent to
doing it without doing as much
background work as they would otherwise
do and that's that's why there is the
concern about just putting a pause
saying let's wait until you're 18 it's
not denying anybody the care and if it's
not happening today then that's not
stopping it either
um and it's it's crazy that it's so hard
to have a discussion about what the
medical facts are and that's what really
makes me feel that we need to have this
pause because if you can't discuss the
facts even in a hearing like this
without being afraid of being called
names how do you do that elsewhere how
do you know what the outcomes are how do
you know the risks so that's why I
believe that this is uh in the public
interest other discussion representative
King thank you Mr chair I'd like to
address one point that representative
Shapiro made and that is it's not Happ
happening here right now and I think the
reason why it's not happening in here
right now is because it hasn't happened
for Millennia uh it would would have
been unfathomable to do these types of
things just a decade ago uh both parties
I think would have even agreed just 10
or 15 years ago that these types of
elective surgeries would have been
Unthinkable and I don't think I don't
think you would have you would have been
very hardpressed to find anybody that
would have supported it
what's changed in the last 10 years is
the culture but truth and falsehoods
have not changed and what this bill does
is it does make a moral statement about
right and wrong and uh I support the the
original bill but the reason why I'm
supporting this amendment is because
while I agreed with every single part of
the original bill um I did agree I did
agree at least in part that
um it was a little Broad in scope um so
that's what I liked about this amendment
was that it Narrows the scope a little
bit but I would like to implore uh
people to vote for the amendment because
um this is a nice compromise and if the
compromise doesn't pass I'll still be
supporting the the uh the original the
original bill because I do believe that
this issue is so important it does need
to be supported immediately before it
does start happening in the state and
once it starts happening then it's going
to be even more difficult to stop so we
need to nip it in the butt as far as I'm
concerned thank you representative
Canon thank you Mr
chair um I circulated a document to you
today U concerning the Harry Benjamin
standards of care and you're GNA say
well why is this being circulated uh
Harry Benjamin was a doctor in the 1950s
that was studying how to care for
transexuals um he formed a um an
association the Harry Benjamin
International gender dysphoria
Association and they produced the first
document discussing the care of
transexual individuals in in um
1979 um so the uh the medical community
has been aware of the need of for care
for transgender transsexual and
transgender individuals you'll note in
the first paragraph it says that the uh
uh the the document that they produce
has been updated six times and the
version of the document you have in
front of you was dated
2001 in 2007 the Harry Benjamin
Association became the world
Professional Association of transgender
Health commonly referred to as
wpath um they have continued to update
the information associated with the care
of transgender individuals and there
whole and even in this document it in
section five it has assessment and
treatment of Children and adolescents
they've improved this section over time
but it does flag uh the uh the care of
adolescents and making sure that people
are that they're evaluated properly um
from many different uh from many
different angles as well as uh in here
is to U provide information on making
sure that people know what the results
are going to be what what risks are um
and this is back in 2001 on this in this
document it has in been it has been
improved over time um based on medical
study information provided in the
medical community they've updated it uh
for procedures and the knowledge that's
been gained in the medical community to
provide proper care for transgender
individuals young and old um I
believe that the the current Amendment
although it's it's a great effort to
limit the the bill um and to recognize
that um there is a need to protect our
our young people I believe that the
medical establishment in uh New
Hampshire is policing itself uh I'm not
sure why we have to enter into uh uh
putting in statute what already exists
in the medical community and um I'm also
concerned that this this document
although does a good job at at um uh
defining defining things um is it could
be subject to change as medical
information is updated for care of
transgender individuals and there's no
mechanism defined in this document as to
how when things are changed in in the
medical information available how does
it get changed within the statutes in
New Hampshire how does it change and and
it can't change as quickly as as the
medical field can change that
information because new statutes will
have to be written to change this
information as posted in our in New
Hampshire so
um I'm also concerned that as um
representative Shapiro has mentioned um
I don't believe u that that this
document is needed I believe that this
document is in search of a problem and I
don't believe there's a problem
currently in New Hampshire um there may
have been in not no information on uh on
uh what if any U uh surgical procedures
have been done in New Hampshire but the
the members of the medical community and
the members of the transgender Community
have not indicated um that these
procedures are being done in New
Hampshire so um for that reason I'm
going to vote against this amendment
mment thank you representative
Palmer so I also appreciate how this has
been um cut down to a much simpler uh
bill but I have um two concerns one is
that you that uh different studies
between 15 n 2015 and 22 are um
mentioned in here and that would sort of
mean that this is going to be con this
would be constantly would have constant
need for um revision which would be
difficult to do in a statute because the
the the data is going to
change um but the bottom line is um from
my point of view I just don't think that
legislating Medical Care is a good idea
I do agree that you know having any
surgery or transgender care under the
age of 18 is really
problematic but and and you do elucidate
areas in here that are um exceptions but
you know are there exceptions that are
not thought of and are we going to get
into the same kind of trouble we have
with other things where um a doctor's
sitting there going like I need to make
a decision but now I need to get the
lawyers to tell me whether this decision
is okay so the bottom line is I really
can't um support this though I think the
intent makes sense and I certainly think
that waiting until people are adults to
make these decisions is what should
happen um but I also think that since
it's not happening in New Hampshire and
you know as you say it could and if it's
abused then I think we need to look at
the um State Board of Medicine to to get
on it and then you can you know then
then we can look at whether a law is
needed representative Murphy and then
representative Lon thank you Mr chairman
um I I don't anticipate that anything I
might say would change anybody's current
opinion but I wanted to make a couple
points that I saw in the amendment that
I don't necessarily agree with um uh on
the third page at the very bottom
talking about enforcement I you know
when somebody says referring somebody
for surgery uh constitutes
unprofessional conduct I I I think
that's totally wrong you know if you
refer somebody to a surgeon it's not the
surgeon's responsibility to basically
say okay I'll do it because I got a
referral they have to make an assessment
so I think that specifically referring
to a surgeon to do a procedure in colge
on that uh unprofessional it would be
unprofessional if they did not refer
when somebody had questions at least for
evaluation so I'd make a point of
contention with that I would also agree
with representative Lyon I think the
data in the research is there's aity of
the data and it's difficult in medicine
to extrapolate to um the general
population as to what is best done for
any individual patient without a lot of
data um however having said that and and
even regardless of the fact that if this
is surgery is not done in New Hampshire
what you are basically doing is two
things you are legislating medicine
which I am terribly against I I don't
think that is appropriate but also you
are putting on the books a statute that
if and when that does become available
whether it's at the tertiary Care
Medical Center or wherever you are
taking tools away from providers that
would need to take care of the patient
so I you know I understand the anx
I have really thought very hard about
this bill I've asked many people about
the bill psychiatrist other patients
constituents and I've come to realize
that this bill is not necessarily
falling down party lines but there are
people that have very strong opinions
about it for and against on both sides
but I don't think a referral to any
provider any other provider is a cause
for unprofessional conduct I don't
believe we should be legislating
medicine like we don't we don't in other
areas and and I I don't believe we
should be taking away potential future
tools in the toolbox for any provider
that needs to take care of a patient so
you know for those reasons even though
the concept of vote for a u an amendment
which I appreciate trying to narrow it
down it still narrows it down to the one
point of content contention where you
are taking away the opportunity possibly
for doing surgery and for that reason
alone even though it is narrow D and I
appreciate the effort the fact that it
still is there to me regardless doesn't
make a bad Bill better in my mind so I
will vote against the amendment and
probably the audit pass or with
Amendment if that were to succeed thank
you thank you representative Lon um
thank you Mr chairman and I want to
thank representative Palmer for bringing
up the Board of Medicine just a week ago
we were here discussing a bill intended
to address the challenges around um
essentially around cardiac surgeon who
was implanting um implantable medical
devices some of which I helped bring to
Market um in a way that um caused harm
to patients and death to patients there
were very very solid protocols
procedures and clinical evidence of the
benefit and of the risks of those
devices they were highly wellknown
yet we still had people who died because
in the practice of medicine those guid
lines and those standards were not
followed that is an was an area where
there was so much information and they
could have relied on a lot of different
people from the device manufacturers
from colleagues and from peers and there
was what and the data was was very large
and significant um when we look to I
want to thank representative Canon for
bringing this document um if you look to
on the Harry Ben Benjamin standards of
care if you look at the end of section
five on the adolescence um it's just
above the psychop therapy with with
adults it's pretty close to the middle
it speaks about in irreversible
interventions in children it says any
surgical intervention should not be
carried out prior to adulthood or prior
to a real life experience of two years
um in the gender role of the sex at
which the Adolescent identifies their
threshold of 18 should be seen as an
eligibility Criterion
and not an indication itself for active
intervention and then going to the
second to uh third to last piece of
paper on the genital surgery on section
12 the eligibility criteria for genital
surgery was legal age of majority in the
patients Nation uh I I recognize that
this moved to the 2007 um W path
guidelines and even looking at the
standard of care 8 from wath it speaks
to respecting the legal age of majority
and any laws surrounding this genital
gender surgery um for these purposes and
respecting those so that um the age of
majority is considered in that clinical
treatment we don't know how it's going
to evolve next if there's a whole bunch
of data and we're seeing we actually see
outcomes and we actually see a benefit
to it I really I this was such a hard
thing to talk about I have a feeling
that if the data shifts the other way
it's not going to be a hard lift for
this to be removed um but there is the
memorializing of what the status is
today that's why it doesn't say current
studies show showed no decrease it says
studies between 2015 and 2022 just as we
talked about the 2006 data on sexual
assaults now being out of date if this
becomes out of date by including that
language it gives a reason for it to be
addressed in the future um I mean we we
need to protect vulnerable people and I
with the lack of data it's just very
concerning and that's why I do see a
role
here representative
Weber thank you I agree with much of
what's been said before um I have a
couple of points um
specifically uh to representative Leon's
arguments which is that if we enact a
Prohibition there will be no more
data so there won't be anything to
evolve there will be nothing to
evaluate um and so that
seems like a self-fulfilling prophecy
um I also just uh in thinking of whether
to vote for this amendment I have the
same concerns that have already been
expressed I won't go over them again uh
but you know there's always the question
about do I do something that I think is
better than the
original and and um
my the way I come down on this is that
the folks with lived experience in this
area have asked for this amendment not
to be passed so uh that's what I'm going
to vote for thank you repres
Missour thank you Mr chair I've heard
multiple times today that we are not
doing this in New Hampshire and I was on
the subcommittee that dug into this a
little bit we reached out to Dartmouth
Hitchcock and others did not receive a
definite response but here is what we
did find and this is right on Dartmouth
Hitchcock's website we offer a wide
variety of services for every stage of
your journey
including gender affirming hormone
therapy G
GT for adults and adolescents gender
affirming surgery including Top surgery
bottom surgery and facial feminization
surgery gynecological Services that's on
Dartmouth Hitchcock this is on Elliot
the plastic and reconstructive surgery
team at Elliott Hospital are experts in
gender affirming Top surgery to remove
unwanted breast Tiss tissue or to create
breast using
implants it's very clear to me that this
is being done in New Hampshire but yet
we were told again and again that it
wasn't so I have I'm
now we need to do like go further and do
an interim study on what's really
happening in New Hampshire um because
and and I said this in subcommittee but
I want everybody to hear this this is
not an attack on the lgbtq community
this is taking one step in trying to
protect the the children until they're
adults and are able to make their
decisions at that point that's what this
is this is not an attack on anyone this
is asking people to wait until
children are adults and can make their
own decisions what you do at that point
is up to you but this is evidence that
this is being done in New Hampshire so
we need to take a state back step back
and do more research and find out what's
really
happening
so can I would like to move to interim
study
please can I oh I'm sorry that and there
are other people to sorry I'm getting
um representative kushman do you have
your hand up or yeah okay thank you Mr
chairman
um so yeah I would like to um continue
on on kind of that train of thought
again just bringing back to it's really
members of the committee who keep saying
that these aren't happening in New New
Hampshire Dartmouth said that they are
rare genital gender reassignment
surgeries are rare and they actually
answered one of my questions that um
there may be circumstances where they
need to be done and then I asked further
can you tell me what the protocols are
in deciding whether to go forward with a
surgery on a minor or not um and they
never uh supplied me with the policies
and procedures which all medical
facilities have down to how to do a
catheter you should have a a procedure
manual that explains that what the
facilities procedures are um and they
should be you know you grab it off of a
desk um it should have been made
available to us and um just circling
back to um regulating Medical
Care um I see a lot of picking and
choosing um in this committee
particularly um I brought a bill when
people were dying and they needed
something um other than remes severe um
which was also killing people um they
needed something and it could have been
made available and there were Decades of
re re uh Decades of research available
showing it was safe and we just wanted
to make PE make people have the option
to have the choice to basically a right
to try you know um and uh many people in
this committee also voted against that
and I think that you know that was an
opportunity to step back and say well we
don't want to regulate medic uh medicine
but in that instance it was um and it
was kept that way and something that
could have helped people was not made
available um we also require
parents um to obtain certain kinds of
medical care and I think that that is
more of an overreach of the state than
are requiring lenses who are in our
jurisdiction um and are not just just
the people um and and and to say that um
you know trying to protect their rights
and ensuring that they're not um
especially children being becoming a
victim of a short-sided decision that
was maybe made with less information um
than they needed at the time and without
the
data
um I just think you know we we preclude
uh vaginal births after cesarians if
you've had two of them you don't you
can't have Midwifery care there are many
instances where we try to do things to
protect the best interests of the public
and this is one of those situations um I
I respect that many people have these
lived experiences and have have voiced
their support for um allowing these
surgeries for minors but there are many
other voices telling us that they went
through it and that the care was
not as in um they didn't get the
informed consent that they should have
uh and that they didn't really know what
the adverse effects were going to be for
the rest of their lives that they now
have to deal with um and they've been
calling on us to do something to protect
kids so I I think this is the proper
place for us to step in and and as far
as the medical establishment in this
area policing themselves well against
the W path guidelin which um you know
say at least six months of therapy the
New Hampshire Coalition for gender
diversity website offers a list of um
resources for um kids who are struggling
with gender issues and they offer
contact kids and adults they offer
contact info for psychotherapists who
will write letters um recommending
hormones and surgery after one to two
visits that's that doesn't happen in six
months um I mean I guess it could but I
wouldn't call that consistent care for
that amount of time as the W paath
standards call for so we brought these
amendments forward with the w paath
standards in mind and we found that they
even though Dartmouth Hitchcock their
website says that they follow those
standards we've found a lot of holes in
that and that doesn't seem to be holding
up to be true and this is where the
legislature needs to step in so thank
you representative Canon you had your
mic on for a while are you did you want
to speak or yes I do okay go ahead um
and then representative McKay and then
representative veral there was a a qu
there was a comment about Elliot
Hospital um and providing surgicals
surgical procedures for um people under
the age of 18 I I know that I I've been
contacted a number of times by U female
to male people who have um have wanted
surgery full masectomy and um denied
that because they were under the age of
18 and they needed a parental signature
so they had to wait and couldn't they
really struggled because they they
wanted the surgery um but they had to
wait until they were the age of 18
because U Elliot wouldn't do the surgery
procedures uh the the same thing has
been true for for hormones um so I know
in working with many families I I know
that they their child has had to wait
for
testosterone uh injections or for estr
estrogen treatment um so so it it's been
painful for a lot of transgender youth
but they've had to adhere to the
guidelines because their providers here
in the state of New Hampshire have been
holding true to what's in the W path
recommendations and the
DSM um and and so uh as I as I have read
this document and I appreciate the
pieces that are here I have to go back
to why would we put medical information
into statute when it it's being changed
um and policing policing across the
across the world uh to take care of our
children as well as
adults thank you representative McKay
and then representative
bville thank you Mr
chairman uh I've been on this committee
for many many years
and one of the things that seems to keep
coming back is our desire to teach
doctors how to practice uh
medicine uh over and over and over again
uh my experience has been that the
Physicians who are around this committee
and have been do not support that
approach and that
they much more look into the kind of
professional training that Physicians
and surgeons and other
Specialists
um have uh so I am totally against
legislation that
tells uh Physicians and other Prof
professionals how to practice uh their
work uh I I think it's inappropriate I
always have and I think uh uh I've I
don't know
recently uh how
many of you have had the number of calls
on 619 that I've had um partly because
of conversion therapy which thank God
didn't get uh put into this amendment uh
but I am totally U uh in
a in support of Physicians uh who feel
that they get their training elsewhere
and they should not be getting trained
in any sense by the
legislature thank you very much and I
will speak against this thank you
representative McKay representative
verville and then representative
Lon thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee so um just two quick things
one is is if this bill passes and
becomes law it is not a self-fulfilling
prophecy in in any form shape or manner
New Hampshire is a small state and we
make up what approximately onethird of
1% of the population of the United
States we are one small state um perhaps
choosing a different path than uh other
states in the in the union this this is
not a national bill we're talking about
further we are we are one country uh on
a global platform and and other
countries will um support this this type
of stuff and and other countries won't
so so this is certainly not a
self-fulfilling prophecy by by any
stretch of the
imagination the point that
really brought my attention to to want
to speak to
you is that I reject the
notion that we need to have some list of
victims that have already been
hurt before we pass
legislation intended to prot protect
people this is proactive
legislation to protect the most
vulnerable among us and that is our
minor children and to say or to suggest
or to
require that some number of victims
be
generated before we take up such a
matter for me is a bridge too far and
for that
reason I will support the
amendment and I will support OTP or otpa
whichever uh may may come and and those
are the two points I just want you to
give some serious consideration to as
you uh as you weigh this on your own
minds thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
McKay for bringing up one section of our
statutes where we do legislate the
practice of medicine this amendment
moved this protection for minor children
regarding the genital gender
reassignment surgeries to fall
immediately after our prohibition on
conversion therapy if we believe that
doctors are following the guidelines and
following best practices that statute is
unnecessary however this committee did
not not support repealing that law last
year this committee took the position
that there are times in which we
legislate the practice of medicine and
by refusing to update those statutes to
better reflect more inclusive language
to our n non-binary friends and to only
have language that support people on a
direct transitional path with one end
point we continue to have a statute that
legislates the practice of Medicine this
would be adding another protection for
minors and I have trouble seeing a
consistency between supporting the
prohibition on conversion therapy for
minors and because and then opposing
this under the GU that we do not
legislate the practice of medicine if we
can come to more broad Universal
application of how we apply the laws
then we can find a lot more agreement
going forward but right now it is our
practice to sometimes legislate the
practice of medicine and I believe that
as representative rille said we don't
need to have a list of victims first to
act other discussion representative
Merchant thank you Mr
chair I find it kind of ironic we talk
about parents
rights and the sacrament of the
importance of parents and the ability
for a parent to speak on behalf of for
the
child it's been in our history for years
it's been part of our civilization that
parents are there take responsibility
for their
children and the state stays out of
it we don't get into how the parent is
trying to make judgments for their
children yet here we are talking about
getting involved with that area of
parents and saying these are things you
can't decide on because we're not going
to let you do it so so I'm really
wrestling with the issue of how do we
somehow straddle that and saying parents
have certain rights but parents don't
have certain rights where does the state
come down not just with Medical Practice
of medicine but how we interfere with
Parenthood and that's kind of one of the
concerns I have here is that there's
no place I think in some ways for the
state to get involved with how parents
take care of the children fundamentally
number two when you start looking at the
issue if you feel that there's going to
be a question about the parents not
speaking on behalf of their children
correctly there's no vehicle in this
amendment or in this bill that they
could go to the court and have the court
be sure that the child is not being
cered the child is hearing what needs to
be talked about the parents are fully
informed on the consent there's some
safety valve in the whole process to
ensure that all parties are fully
informed before it's done and the third
thing about the enforcement we're
dealing with the position here in the
state of New Hampshire who makes a
referral but we're not talking about the
surgeon in another state who actually
does the surgery and I go back to what
president Linn said maybe we can't do
that because we can't go across state
lines but for those three fundamental
issues I cannot support the underlying
Amendment nor the underlying Bill thank
you other
discussion represent Senator bille thank
you U Mr chairman
so so while I fully appreciate and
embrace parental rights in making uh
decisions that they believe are in the
best interest of their children the
state does in fact get
involved at a great number of different
levels of what one may and what one may
not do with or to their children so if I
am starving in
poverty and I have young
children that if they could find a job
could work to help feed the family under
a certain age that is simply not allowed
it is simply not allowed and while
certain corporal
punishment may be allowed certainly
there's a threshold of corporal
punishment which is not allowed by the
state because it is deemed abusive
correctly
so so to say that well you know we're
going to we're just going to support
cart ban parental rights over the life
of their children and we should keep the
state out of it I agree it gets it gets
flipped back and forth in each side of
of a lot of issues like to to point to
that but but there is no consistency
there there is none and and for that
reason I think to use it as a cart
blanch sort of um reason to decide one
way or another on a bill I I don't think
it's applicable I think you have to
weigh you have to weigh what it is that
we're considering disallowing parents to
have the authority to do over their
children there are there are times and
places where where disallowing that is
valid and there are other places where
uh full full allowance is applicable and
so really that's a decision that you
have to make in your heart and that's a
decision you have to make in your mind
but to look at State Statute and and how
we deal with those things and say well
that that guides me 100% I I don't think
that that argument really um stands up
at least respectfully at least for my
for myself thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman I just want to weigh and I'll
be brief on the parental rights issue uh
this bill doesn't even address parents
this bill um addresses Physicians uh
that they are not uh uh they are not
authorized to perform certain procedures
uh physicians in New Hampshire are
licensed entities they engage in a
contract with the state they're granted
certain privileges um and uh as they
engage in that license they also have to
follow the rules of that license
um that is much different than applying
rules to parents who have not contracted
with the state and agreed to those rules
other than
uh giving their consent for their um
duly elected officials to act on their
behalf um it's less appropriate to put
um restrictions on them but there are
many and uh lastly Mr chairman I just
wanted to mention
um
the
um the point that I forgot I'm sorry
okay the
discussion I'm seeing no other
discussion all right I'll ask the clerk
to call the roll the motion is out to
pass on Amendment
2023 2451
H representative Leon yes representative
kushman yes representative Lynn yes
representative K yes representative Reed
yes representative Seth King yes
resentative Missour yes
representative yes representative POA
yes representative Weber no
representative McKay no representative
uh
fedus no representative Canan no
Representative nutup no representative
Shapiro no representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no representative
Palmer no represent Priest No
representative McDonald
yes motion uh the motion uh fails uh 10
to 10 is there a motion on the main
amendment I on the main bill now on HB
619 representative King did you want to
make a motion yes I'd like to make a
motion ought to pass for HB 619 is there
a second representative missou yes I'll
second okay would you like to speak to
your motion representative king or has
it all been said no thank you uh Mr
chairman I would just like to uh
reiterate that this is a um there is a
moral stance being taken here um this
isn't just technical um what we are
saying effectively is that there is such
a thing as right and wrong and um
and what is not necessarily being done
in New Hampshire but what is being done
to children around the country uh is
wrong and I would just like to add that
um you know children are unable to
consent in this regard U we know how
vulnerable and impressionable children
are when it comes to just pure pressure
but imagine when there is uh teacher
pressure um Hollywood pressure um
pressure from many different sides
parental pressure to do something that
these children are going to later grow
up to absolutely regret and they're
going to have a lot of resentment for
really every body who pushed them into
this and um I don't want to see that
happen in New Hampshire so I'm doing
what I can to stop that practice in New
Hampshire we had an opportunity to make
a compromise and to narrow the scope of
the bill that compromise was not
accepted as for the rest of the bill I
supported the rest of the bill as well I
think it's a great Bill my only
contention is it would have been three
bills but aside from that all of the all
of the issues are Spott on and I support
them and um thank you for your time Mr
chair thank you other
discussion representative
Canon um I have a problem with the HB
619 in general um it's overall scope uh
as uh representative King has flagged it
those pieces should have been broken up
into multiple pieces uh uh I have an
issue especially um with with the focus
on on uh transgender children especially
in school and stuff we have focused in
on a protected class of individuals and
feel that this is a discriminatory Bill
uh right to start off with but I also
flag that the uh conversion therapy
piece is not purely related to
transgender individuals and we didn't
address the uh gay and lesbian Community
or or U non-binary folks uh so we we
didn't get enough information from those
from feedback from those individuals to
make a decision of that part of the bill
um I Al I I also feel that we've really
um separated and and identified the uh
transgender kids as being different than
every other child in the school system
um for that reason I I can't vote for
this bill at all thank you other
discussion representative
palazov uh I support this bill uh as
written uh I think that uh we need to
return to science-based approach and
suicide SS admitted in a suggestive
survey is not equal to actual death uh
we we we see that there's a lot of
observational studies on benefit of uh
those treatments but no relevant
randomized control trials in child and
adolesence on benefits of removing
healthy organs or some other procedures
that we are trying to address and I
would even question if it's actual
medicine when we remove healthy organs
uh but uh uh New Hampshire as was said
is not the only jurisdiction and some
other liberal jurisdictions moved to a
more cautious approach including friends
they K Norway Sweden in Finland uh the
comprehensive study found that uh this
gender affirming care is associated with
cardiovascular disease risk with
osteoporosis with infertility with
increased cancer risk and increased
thrombosis risk so there are side
effects to every medication so saying
that of of label Medica by puberty
blockus is absolutely safe it's false
like every
medication have side effects especially
when we mess up with uh normal hormonal
development of the Body for this reasons
I support this Bill thank you thank you
representative Canon um just as a
reminder to people uh the uh House Bill
619 wasn't just the surgical procedures
um the original title of the bill was
prohibiting gender transition procedure
tees for minors relative to sex and
gender in public schools and relative
the de to the definition of conversion
therapy so there's much more to House
Bill 619 than just surgical procedures
there was an a lot of information uh
control of children in school and what
they could and couldn't do um and uh the
use of uh pronouns and a number of other
things that were in 619 to control what
transgender students could or couldn't
do U so so this goes far beyond the
conver the U TR the surgical procedures
and U and again I will vote against it
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um I recognize that this goes
further than the amendment that we had
worked on in good faith and that we
thought that there was going to be a
chance of coming together in agreement
um now that hasn't happened and then
it's split on party lines I think that
we need to move this forward to the
floor and that's why I'm supporting H to
pass I wish it was as amended but I'll
support H to pass so that we can move it
to the floor other
discussion seeing none uh we'll move on
to the vote I'll ask the clerk to call
the r a motion is ought to pass on HB
619 representative leam yes
representative kushman yes
representative Lynn yes representative
kofalt yes representative Reed yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative veril yes representative
pelosof yes representative Weber no
representative McKay no Representative
fedus no representative Canon no
representative Nutter upam
representative
Shapiro no representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no representa
ative Palmer no representative PRI no
representative McDonald yes tend
to Mr chairman I would move itl okay is
there a
second okay um can substitute
second um perhaps somebody elseed
representative Shapiro second Sorry Miss
representative priest I just don't want
to VI it any I don't think it matters
but let's not that problem okay Merchant
uh representative webert do you want to
speak to your motion or has it all been
said I think it's all been said and I
think it's all been said by everyone so
I think we could just proceed to the
vote
okay yeah I think that that's a good
point um Mr clerk if you're ready a
motion is an expedient to legislate on
HB
619 representative Leon
no Representative kushman no
representative Lynn no representative
kof
no representative Reed no representative
Seth King no representative Missour no
representative reveal no Representative
peloso no representative
Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative fedus yes representative
Canon yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest yes
representative McDonald
no 10 okay this will go to the floor
with no
recommendation okay and then the final
bill for us today we need an easy one
after that um SB 236 uh representative
Weber and I offered an amendment uh you
should have been represent
representative Lon was kind enough to
distribute it uh earlier uh 2023 hyen
244h uh simply changes the date uh when
the report needs to be done uh honored
before SE November 1st
2024 it had previously said November 1st
2023 uh so I will move the amendment out
to pass I would second
that is a uh and and again it's just a
it's just a housekeeping thing it was uh
an oversight or a mistake in the
original bill so that's why we've done
this uh any other discussion on this uh
motion what's the amendment number uh 20
4408 okay thank
you and seeing no discussion I'll uh
when you're ready Mr
please call a roll motion is ought to
pass on that
Amendment representative leam yes
representative kushman yes
representative Lynn yes representative
kofalt yes representative Reed yes
representative Seth Kings yes
representative mour yes representative
reveal yes representative POF yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes yes representative fedus yes
representative
Canon yes representative Nutter upam
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest yes
chairman McDonald yes that I like those
I know you
do uh this time I'll move out to pass uh
as amended on svb 23
six representative wo seconds any
discussion seeing none when you're ready
Mr
CLK
okay representative Lam yes
representative kushman yes
representative
King representative Lynn yes
representative kofalt yes representative
um Reed yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative ril yes representative
pelosof yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative priest
yes chairman McDonald yes 20 to nothing
okay there's no objection we'll put the
uh we will send that to the consent
calendar okay uh I believe our work is
done today um again thank you
all uh Representatives uh 619
representative Seth King you'll do the
uh to pass and representative Weber you
will do the inexpedient to
legislate I believe that's
representative Canon oh okay you had
made the motion though right I thought I
did make the motion okay representative
Canon you'll do
it sure
okay Mr certainly go
ahead I just wanted to take this
opportunity to wish everybody a
wonderful holidays and thank you for all
your work and thank you
for struggling with the issues we've
struggled with and and collaborating on
those we've been able tooll collaborate
on happy holidays everybody I Echo that
and again thank you for to our
substitutes thank you to the committee
for all your hard work this past year
certainly want to thank the vice
chairman for filling in numerous times
during my my medical experiences and and
certainly thank the ranking member for
her uh her advice and her her motivation
at times and uh and again thank you all
and as as representative wber said Happy
Thanksgiving and a happy holiday season
everyone Mr chair please get those
reports in Mr chair when are the
committee reports due um uh again if I
could get them in the next couple of
days U who's who's asking oh
representative mour yeah if you could
get them in the next couple of days so I
can review them and get them over to
committee services around midweek that
would be
great um because they're going to have a
lot of other reports coming in and is
that okay Christina we get them into
your midweek
I know you'd like him right now but
uh okay all right let's shoot for
tomorrow then even if it's later in the
day thank
you